this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people tease the link in
the description get a two month free
trial about 3,700 kilometers southwest
of Hawaii and 3700 kilometers northeast
of Australia lie the Marshall Islands
getting here is not particularly easy
the only flights from the United States
are through Honolulu only with United
and only a few days of the week which
helps explain why only about 6000 people
visit each year 16 a day on average but
once you arrive getting around is quite
easy while the country is spread out
across a thousand islands and
twenty-nine atolls all together the size
of Washington DC about 40% of its 75,000
people live on his Capital Majuro there
are generously four hotels a couple ATMs
and one main road no traffic lights no
street names a taxi downtown costs about
50 cents or across the island at most
two US dollars some may see it's
isolation from the rest of the world as
inconvenient but for the people of the
Marshall Islands that's its charm
life here is relaxed carefree and rather
slow cars rarely move much faster than
25 miles an hour
appointments are loosely scheduled and
Hawaiian shirts the national dress code
in the last few years however the world
has been intruding as sea levels rise
its beaches are slowly being swallowed
by the ocean and unfortunately the
Marshall Islands are almost entirely
Beach's most land is barely 6 feet above
sea level and in many areas only four
five hundred feet wide so narrow you can
almost always see water from two
opposite sides some years like 2013
floods damaged hundreds of homes schools
and stop planes from being able to land
the same thing is happening around the
world but here on small faraway islands
the clock is ticking and the question of
what to do yet unanswered for the first
time in history countries may totally
disappear not politically but literally
and physically where once lay a thriving
tropical paradise community may one day
be only a floating sign explaining what
once was
unless something can be done to save
them like many islands and strategically
useful places the Republic of the
Marshall Islands has a long history of
foreign imperialism first by the Spanish
then the Germans some brief contact with
the British invaded by the Japanese in
World War one and finally during the
next world war captured from Japan by
the United States it and its neighbors
now known as Palau the Northern Mariana
Islands and the Federated States of
Micronesia were put under the
administration of the US Navy as the
Trust Territory of the Pacific Islands
later in the 80s and 90s the islands
slowly gained their independence the US
government officially recognized its
Constitution allowed it to hold
elections and signed a compact of free
association today the Marshall Islands
are less than the United States overseas
territory like Guam or Puerto Rico but
much more than simply a friendly foreign
Ally legally an Associated State the
islands have access to its federal
agencies including the National Weather
Service Federal Aviation Administration
and postal service the u.s. also agrees
to protect and defend the country
although it cannot declare war on its
behalf this part of the United States
but not really relationship can create
some awkward situations
in 2015 the Iranian Navy seized and
detained immersed container ship
traveling 12,000 kilometers away in the
Strait of Hormuz Maersk is a Danish
company and the ship owned by a
Singapore based operator
however for tax avoidance and legal
reasons it was registered like many
ships in the Marshall Islands which
because of its defense responsibilities
technically obligated the US Navy to
respond with a destroyer although it
later clarified it won't do so in the
future besides a small coke
breadfruit and fishing industry the
Marshall Islands just doesn't have that
many ways to make money without many
natural resources it's had to resort to
creative ways of bringing in revenue
like becoming the second most popular
ship registry in the world after Panama
and although sometimes lucrative these
niche markets can make the entire
economy of a small nation vulnerable to
the whims of foreign actors its neighbor
kiri boss for example is geographically
blessed as the closest non-american soil
to the Hawaiian Islands so despite
having almost no infrastructure or
tourist attractions it's taboo Ron
island became a regular stop for
Hawaiian cruises who as foreign
registered ships are legally required to
stop at least once outside the country
recently though Norwegian cruises
introduced American flag ships rendering
the detour unnecessary and tab Iran back
where it started with virtually no
source of income in a similar vein Palau
is lucky to be home to a unique species
of golden jellyfish which draw tourists
from around the world
unfortunately they too are slowly dying
which researchers suspect is due in part
to rising sea temperatures so inevitably
with no other options these states turn
to diplomacy of the 17 other UN members
who recognize Taiwan as a country for
example 9 our small island nations it
shares embassies with the Marshall
Islands and Taiwan's president at the
time was the first head of state to
officially visit the country the islands
also receive 78 million dollars in US
foreign assistance each year of the 1.5
billion they've been promised from 2004
to 24 of course there's no such thing as
a free lunch and perhaps nowhere is that
more apparent than here at the giant
concrete American built radioactive dome
on on we talked at all when the u.s.
assumed control of the islands in the
40s it used them as a nuclear test site
for some of the largest and most
destructive bombs in history including
the famous Castle Bravo at 6:45 on March
1st 1954 it's mushroom cloud could be
seen 250 miles or 400 kilometers away
eventually reaching for
7,000 feet or 14 kilometers expanding at
220 miles an hour and leaving a 250 foot
deep hole in the ocean the explosion was
two and a half times stronger than
expected 15 megatons of TNT instead of
the predicted six it instantly destroyed
many of their measuring instruments
contaminated a nearby Japanese fishing
crew and although inhabitants had been
evacuated beforehand because of the
unexpected size of the explosion covered
surrounding islands in a white snow like
radioactive powder children played with
it not knowing of its cancerous effects
decades later in 1977 four thousand US
soldiers were sent to clean up the
fallout over three years they collected
73,000 cubic meters of soil and four
hundred chunks of plutonium 239 an
isotope with a radioactive half-life of
24,000 years it was then thrown into the
crater created by the explosion and
covered in a 328 foot or 100 meter 18
inch thick UFO shaped dome this was said
to be only a temporary solution as it
was not covered with a lining meaning
there's a good chance according to the
US Energy Department that the toxic
radioactive material has already begun
leaking out into the ocean where
Marshall Islanders fish and play today
in exchange for its payments the US
continues to operate the Ronald Reagan
ballistic missile defense test site the
US Army is one of the biggest employers
on the islands which have a higher per
capita enlistment rate than any state
and because of its proximity to the
equator SpaceX has launched several of
its rockets here in the past so while
the Marshall Islands have little
leverage with the u.s. there is some
hope it will be forced to deal with
rising sea levels as it begins to affect
military operations aerial images show
six islets disappear between 2007 and 14
alone although not all Islands are
equally at risk
some like the Maldives are almost
completely flat offering no place to
retreat
others like Palau have upland areas
residents can move to each is
differently susceptible to erosion and
some have more
less powerful waves a few islands like
Tuvalu may actually grow as storms carry
sediment which varies with seasonal
trade winds but almost everywhere on
earth will be somehow affected Venice
the Everglades Waikiki and Alaska are
all at risk
one small Alaskan town the last frontier
of the last frontier Shishmaref has been
losing ten of its thirteen hundred feet
every year as winter waves slam into the
island and permafrost underneath it
thaws weakening its foundation all these
islands have essentially three options
mitigate innovate or relocate if land is
disappearing the obvious solution is the
China or Dubai approach add more
barriers and jetties could also dampen
the blow of incoming waves
unfortunately these would likely harm
marine life be extremely costly and as
long as the sea continues to rise
require continual maintenance better of
course would be slowing climate change
altogether but raising awareness is
quite difficult it's geographically far
away happening relatively slowly and the
dynamics of wave exposure aren't the
most exciting the trifecta of not
getting news coverage another option is
to innovate try something anything no
matter how bizarre sounding to generate
revenue or attention in 2018 the
Marshall Islands signed the sovereign
currency Act which created its own
national crypto currency if it works the
plan would give the islands more control
over their economy and new funds to
experiment with another idea proposed by
the mayor of the wrong lap at all is to
be able to quote the next hong kong a
special administrative region in the
middle of the pacific the idea is to use
the Marshall Islands special
relationship with the u.s. to create a
tax haven and pathway to the mainland
much like Hong Kong's special status
with China most islands are trying a mix
of these ideas while also planning for
the perhaps more likely worst-case
scenario relocation in 2014
Kira Voss purchased a 20 square
kilometre patch of land from the Church
of England in Fiji it's president
announced we would hope not to put
everyone on this one piece of land but
if it became absolutely
necessary yes we could do it the
Marshall Islands meanwhile has an easier
escape as part of its agreement with the
United States its citizens are allowed
to live work and study on the mainland
without a visa about 1/3 of Marshall
Islanders have migrated many to
Springdale Arkansas or Salem Oregon
although there's a catch
Marshall E is living on the mainland are
not legally considered citizens but also
not immigrants or refugees they're
permanent non immigrants which makes
them ineligible for some federal
services including Medicaid and if the
compact of free association is not
renewed when it ends in 2024 this door
will close entirely years ago the US
government swept its radioactive
misdeeds quite literally under the rug
and as sea levels rise it seems to be
doing much the same ignore the problem
as it grows until one day it's too late
today the Marshall Islands tomorrow
Waikiki eventually New York those who've
survived drowning report the same
pattern at first an overwhelming feeling
of panic arms flailing legs kicking
anything no matter how ridiculous to try
to get the attention of the people
around you eventually though dread turns
to tranquility a calmness a dangerous
complicity a feeling that it's too late
that nothing can be done the reality is
it's not too late yet the world is well
into the panic stage but also at serious
risk of turning into acceptance it
always feels like you can just hold your
breath a few more seconds until you
can't when the US military arrived on
the Marshall Islands in 1946 asking
locals to give up their homes for what
they claimed was the good of humankind
their leader responded with the words
now imprinted on the flag of Bikini
Atoll everything is in the hands of God
now the future isn't ours
not everyone has an up-close view of
rising sea levels but I for one can
really relate to the feeling of having
your head underwater being totally
overwhelmed with so much to do and so
little time to do it recently after
watching this class on Skillshare I
started planning pretty much every
minute
my day I used to put everything on a
to-do list but let's be honest I usually
ended the week with more to do than when
I started
it's a lot easier to add to the list
than remember to check it I highly
recommend checking out Thomas Frank's
class on productivity or one of the
others on design programming investing
cooking and lots of other topics you can
try Skillshare today with a two month
free trial with a link in the
description for the first 500 people
thanks to skill share and to you for
watching